in July 20 20 fresh TV shows new films
and a whole lot of classic entertainment
will arrive on Netflix looking for a
place to start
good news you're exactly where you need
to be consider this your personal guide
to the best of what's coming to Netflix
in July 2020 there aren't a ton of new
action movies coming to Netflix in July
2020
but there's one notable comic book
adaptation on the horizon that's a
must-see on July 10th Netflix will
unveil the old guard a kind of superhero
ask sci-fi action er about a group of
immortal assassins for hire
starring Charlize Theron the old guard
is based on the image comics miniseries
of the same name writer Greg Rucka whose
lists of comic book credits feature a
number of other women led action stories
like White House and Queen and country
also wrote the screenplay for the old
guard in the film Theron plays Andy the
oldest member of the titular old guard
who takes on the role of mentor to a new
immortal Niall Freeman played by Kiki
Lane if we're back with an exciting cast
and a fresh new representation of the
curse of immortality the old guard is
definitely the action movie to watch on
Netflix this July of course if you're
excited about Zack Snyder's Justice
League coming to HBO max in 2021 you can
get your Snyder fixed by rewatching is
2011 action fantasy flick sucker punch
available July 1st and if you want to
take a vacation to Mars you can go there
with Arnold Schwarzenegger in 1990s
Total Recall also available at the first
of the month the 2004 Nicholas Sparks
adaptation the notebook is coming to
Netflix on July 18th let's be honest
even though you've probably seen it many
times before watching Ryan Gosling and
Rachel McAdams have a love affair is
something you can always watch again
speaking of mcadams the oscar-winning
film spotlights which dramatizes the
incredible true story of how the Boston
Globe uncovered decades of hidden abuse
within the Catholic Church arrives on
Netflix July 22nd spotlights may take
some dark turns but the film is
ultimately a triumphant tale of what
good journalism can do to protect the
community from predators if you're a
stateside subscriber looking for a
foreign flick a Polish film the hater
hits Netflix on July 29th a hater
centers on a young man from a poor
background who discovers power and
success through manipulating individuals
and groups online a thriller plucked
from the headlines the hater deals with
not just how but also why someone would
want to destroy an individual's good
name or galvanized a movement with false
propaganda there are plenty of classics
to check out on Netflix in July 2020 as
well catch Will Smith's take on the
namesake a boxing champ in alley
dropping on Netflix on July 1st that
same day Netflix released a mind-bending
sci-fi reincarnation flick Cloud Atlas
and the edward james olmos classic Stand
and Deliver which still inspires us to
remember what a great teacher is capable
of doing for that community obviously
you can't spend all of July getting your
face melted off by action scenes or
worrying about the guy from the haters
somehow being real you also need some
light-hearted comedies in your life
Netflix has those this July the month
kicks off with the great disaster movie
spoof airplane starring Robert Hays as
former fighter pilot Ted striker and
Julie Hagerty as Ted's ex-girlfriend
Elaine a flight attendant if you're more
in the market for the dulcet tones of
Tom Hanks there's a timeless romantic
comedy classic Sleepless in Seattle
arriving on Netflix alongside airplane
on July 1st the big new comedy coming to
Netflix on July 3rd is Desperados
starring Saturday Night Live alum the
scene pedrad Desperados as a road trip
flick about a woman named Wesley who
writes a nasty email to a man named
Jared when she becomes convinced he
ghosted her after a one-night stand but
there's a big romantic comedy twist we
won't spoil here if you're looking for a
goofy offbeat take on a road trip story
Desperados is probably the movie for you
Netflix is also heading back to familiar
territory of the kissing booth 2 coming
out July 24th it's the sequel to the
2018 film of
Elevens her crush and the titular
kissing booth that brings them together
if you're looking to double-dip on road
trip movies in lieu of leaving the house
a Jason Mantzoukas comedy the long-term
road hits Netflix on July 8th wrap up
the month with banana splits their
critically adored coming-of-age comedy
about an unlikely female friendship
arriving on July 26th arriving July 19th
is a complete Tempah docu-series the
last dance which chronicles the end of
Michael Jordan's basketball career no
matter how many ball players come and go
in the NBA Michael Jordan's story
remains the most synonymous with what
makes basketball grace the last unto the
great looking for the pressures of being
Michael Jordan at that time and that's
riveting stuff the classic series
unsolved mysteries is getting a fresh
coat of paint beginning July 1st much
like the original the revamp show will
take on cases of crime death
supernatural and more through the prism
of the detectives and journalists who
study those cases of course the new
unsolved mysteries are still about the
audience might someone watching be able
to solve an unsolved a mystery in the
world of Japanese horror there are a few
franchises more popular than Jiwon or if
you might know it The Grudge on July 3rd
Netflix released Juwan origins a TV
series based upon the film franchise
that explores the inception of this
particular haunting those Netflix Bills
it origin sees a paranormal researcher
obsessively searching for a house still
cursed by the terrible events up a
feller mother and child who lived there
years ago there are also a slew of
classic horror films coming on July 1st
including tobe Hooper's poltergeist as
well as gems like the Al Pacino film the
devil's advocate and the found footage
modern classic Paranormal Activity if
you want to subject your children to
something surprisingly terrifying
there's a 1990 movie The Witches which
is deceptively not so much about witches
as it is the children those witches
transform into mice the witches as a
great starter kit horror movie if your
kid is tough enough to handle a scare or
two on July 2nd the warrior noon the
live-action adaptation of the comic
series Rory an urn Ariella drops on
Netflix the series is about a group of
fighting sisters
do battle with the forces of darkness in
a similar vein to book in the month
the second season of the graphic novel
adaptation the Umbrella Academy comes
out July 31st
while we're steeped in the world of the
other there's Frank Miller's cursed
starring 13 reasons why star Catherine
Langford which comes out July 17th
cursed is a what-if story centered on
the Excalibur and King Arthur legend
split in the direction of a young woman
instead instead of a typical Ithorian
story
this version is focused on the mythical
Lady of the lake if you happen to be
looking for a little more slice of life
goodness in your TV series that's an
adaptation of the classic play 12 Angry
Men coming July 10th called the 12th and
if you're looking for love there's a fun
wedding planning reality series dropping
on July 1st called say I do check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos buy your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]